[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID: I'm pleased to introduced
legendary nature photographer
Art Wolfe.
His accolades could fill
a whole talk by itself,
but that isn't
why you came here.
So I'll just highlight
two quick ones.
He won "Nature's" Best
Photographer Award
of the Year and the North
American Nature Photography
Association's Lifetime
Achievement Award.
He's here to talk
about his new book,
as you can see on the screen,
"Photographs From the Edge--
A Master Photographer's
Insights on Capturing
an Extraordinary World,"
where he presents some
of his techniques
and pictures, the way
he got them from around
the world in some
of the most exciting places
that you can imagine.
Please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Art Wolfe.
ART WOLFE: Thank you.
Well this will be the
first and last time
I ever give this talk.
This is my 100th
book, and my staff
informed me about
a week and a half
ago that I was going
to give this talk.
And I said, now
what was that book?
What was it about?
And it's a look back over
40 years of taking pictures.
That's pretty cool,
but as a public talk,
they're all unrelated stories.
There's no connection.
So I have padded some of
the more interesting stories
in the last couple
days, and those
that arrived five minutes early
saw I was redoing that as well.
So this is very
fresh in my mind.
I thought it was going
to be an hour talk.
David said I have
five minutes max--
[LAUGHTER]
It's a joke.
But I'll talk fast.
So I'm just going to give
you a little bit of history.
I grew up in Seattle.
It was a postwar family.
I was born in 1951.
And when I turned 16, I got
my first car, an old beater,
and started heading
to the mountains.
So vacations were always
in the nearby Cascades
or the Olympics.
And I loved the mountains.
And as I got into
my early 20s, I
started moving up out
of the forested valleys
up onto the very
edges of the glaciers.
Here I am up on Mount Baker.
I have no idea how old I was.
In fact this book,
"Photos From the Edge,"
is a chronological look
back over time with clarity
because I am really bad
at remembering names.
I'm really bad at
remembering where
I was last week, because
my whole life has
been just travel, travel,
travel, no five day workweeks.
It's just gone all the time.
So frequently, and
probably today,
when I look back at a photo,
I'll say it's either 12 or 15
or maybe 20 years ago.
In fact I have not even a clue.
But show me a photo,
and I can tell you
all the things about
that photo, what was
the circumstances around that.
So I have one of those
photographic memories for that.
If I don't know,
I'll just make it up,
because I'm very creative
about that as well.
So here I am.
I went through a phase when I
started climbing the mountains
and renaming peaks.
You might suggest that I
had delusions of grandeur.
I was renaming mountains all
the time, putting flags up
on top of mountains.
And none of those names stuck.
But at that age, you think
you can change the world.
So in 1969 I was on top of
a mountain called Snow King,
and I renamed it Apollo Peak.
Well, or so I thought.
And eventually I became program
chairman of the Boeing Alpine
society.
Though nobody in my family
ever worked for Boeing,
one of my best
friend's father did.
And so we got into the
Boeing climbing club.
And it was one of
those years where there
was nobody working for Boeing.
And so I was named
program chairman,
and suddenly I was now booking
famous speakers and climbers
to our club to give talks.
So I commiserate with David.
And during that
period of time-- now
this is in the early
'70s-- my sphere
of friends started expanding
out into the climbing community.
And eventually I
learned how to climb.
I started guiding
friends and family
up Mount Rainier and the other
volcanoes of the Northwest,
constantly learning
about reading weather
and learning how to belay and
use ice axes and pitons and all
those kind of things that are
required to climb mountains.
And eventually I was
invited to participate
on the first expedition of
the northeast ridge of Mount
Everest, first time
a Western group
was permitted into mainland
China on through to Tibet
and up the northeast
ridge, which
was the route from which George
Mallory and Andrew Irvine
disappeared in the early 1900s.
It was a rag tag group
of Boeing employees.
And the reason we were able,
by the way, to gain that access
is that we were selling
jets now to China.
And so we parlayed that
into an invitation.
So here we are in a blue
bus going across the Tibetan
Plateau.
This was our base
camp at 16,000 feet.
We were on that mountain
for three months.
And we virtually got
to within 800 feet
of the summit on a route that
we had no knowledge about.
There was no Google
Earth back then.
There was no living
person that we could
call about the high route.
There was no ladders placed.
It was virtually
an unknown to us.
And none of us were
professional climbers.
So we were the only
expedition on that mountain
on that winter of 1984
that did not lose a life.
Everybody else was
on the south side,
and it was a brutal
year for climbers.
So these photos,
I was learning how
to take pictures at altitude,
starting at 16,000 feet.
I topped off at around
25,000 feet at the North Col.
And I never went over
there with dreams
of standing on the summit,
but I wanted to go over there
because I studied
history and geography
and I remembered
all the years I was
in junior high and high
school knowing about the Red
Guard of the Maoist troops.
I wanted to see what
Lhasa was and what
Tibet was all about, because
no information really
was coming out at the time.
And so if I had
to stand or climb
on this mountain
for three months,
I would do that just to
have that experience.
But I was learning how to use
foregrounds and backgrounds.
I remember at that
time I was using Nikon
and I had batteries going from
my pocket to keep them warm.
That was attached to
the cameras frequently.
And in that era, film would
break in the super cold
of the temperatures there.
But it was this photo, this
photo that I remember most,
because I was sick
with cerebral edema
early on in the
expedition, which
is the swelling of the
brain in the brain case.
And the remedy for
that is to evacuate you
out and lower elevations.
But in fact there was
a 17,000 foot pass
that we had to get
out, to get me out.
And that was dangerous.
So I stayed in camp, and
eventually over the weeks
I got better.
But I was sick at the
time I took this picture.
I was laying in a tiny
little tent freezing.
And I heard these sounds
that sounded like cow bells.
And out of the blowing mist
and snow came these yaks,
caked in snow.
And even at the moment I
took the picture I thought,
there's nothing in this
image that says modern times.
If Marco Polo had a
camera back in the day,
he surely would have being able
to take a picture like that.
And it changed my life, because
though I started in Seattle
with pictures of wood ducks on
Green Lake and climbing Mount
Rainier and all
those kind of things,
it was seeing cultures that
really haven't changed much--
and I knew en route to
Tiber and to the mountain
that I saw my first
TVs in Lhasa and I
thought, oh my God, these TVs
are going to really open up
the world to the people.
Cultures will inevitably
change, and they would.
So when I was photographing
Tibetan people-- because they
all arrived in Lhasa,
Tibet on February 27, 1984.
It was the lunar new year
of that particular year.
So there were
thousands of pilgrims
that had ventured from
all corners of Tibet.
And when I was
photographing them,
it really was obvious
that they had never
been photographed before,
because they would just
stare at the camera with
no reaction, no hesitation,
no giggles.
You know, all the
things that we feel
when we're being
photographed, they just
look blankly into the camera.
And I knew if I survived
this expedition,
this is where I would like to
spend much of my future, which
would be traveling the
world to remote places,
photographing cultures that
would change with time.
And that's, in fact,
much of what I've done.
Though David eloquently
introduced me
as a nature photographer, I see
myself as more of a journalist.
I photograph virtually
everything besides weddings,
bar mitzvahs, and graduations.
Everything else from back alleys
of cities around the planet,
mining it for the abstracts,
a lot of cultural work, nudes,
wildlife, landscapes,
cultural, anything
that piques my interest,
I'll photograph.
The most interesting
story for me,
being on that mountain
for three months,
is you get used to blue
sky, gray rock, and snow.
And my background's
painting and art.
I love color and things
that nourish my soul.
And there was nothing up there.
And yet there was
this monastery,
one of the highest
monasteries on the planet,
called the Rongbuk Monastery.
It had been bombed to
oblivion by the Maoist troops
as they were invading Tibet.
And so I would go down there
and just explore the rubble
of this ancient monastery.
Nobody was living
there at the time.
And it was on my
third trip that I
started noticing
these murals that were
exposed to the harsh elements.
And on the fourth
trip, I started
to see an opening in
the corner on the floor.
I started pulling rocks away.
And I saw that there
was a chamber in there
that was largely intact.
So I went back to
camp, got a headlamp,
and came back and explored.
And this is what I
found, amazing murals.
Not perfect, but colorful
and beautiful nonetheless.
And I delighted on bringing
other members of the expedition
down to discover this discovery.
Since then, from
what I understand,
the Rongbuk Monastery is
repopulated with monks.
It has been rebuilt. But back
then, that's what it was.
I lost 45 pounds
in three months.
So I highly recommend
it for losing weight.
Look at that
Walkman, pretty hip.
Walked around in long
johns, yeah, stylish.
I went back to Mount
Everest two years later
and saw what most
people see when
they go into the Khumbu Valley.
This is the route from
which most expeditions
will launch for the summit.
You remember "Into This Air,"
the book by Jon Krakauer?
He is a friend of mine,
as was Scott Fischer.
He lived a couple
blocks from me.
And Scott would always
come to my summer parties.
And so when I watched the
movie earlier this year,
I think they got
Scott pretty well,
Jake Gyllenhaal as the actor.
But this is one of the more
famous mountains en route.
It's called Ama Dablam.
It's very fluted with
avalanche slopes, indeed
a very difficult but
sublimely beautiful mountain
rising out of the mist.
One year I went down
to Easter Island.
It was, again, in
the very early '80s.
And I had a headlamp.
I was traveling by myself.
I camped out under these moais.
And this is-- you know,
I'm not a conspiracy--
I just don't believe in
phenomenon unless I see it.
But I had such vivid
dreams sleeping
below these giant
monolithic statues
that I swear to God
somebody touched me,
and I was so frozen with
fear that it took me
a couple minutes before I moved.
And I sat up and I looked
around with my headlamp,
and there was nothing there.
And I'll never forget that.
That's nearly 40
years ago and I still
have that as a vivid memory.
One year I had the
worst trip of my life.
I went to Siberia in
the winter of 1986.
Everybody was unhappy
in Siberia in 1986.
There was not much
to photograph.
I was invited by the
Russian government
to come and photograph
Lake Baikal in Siberia
so that there would
be tens of thousands
of tourists that would follow.
And in fact I was so
miserable that I never really
promoted it.
But the only shot that I really
liked on that entire trip
was this group of
overturned boats.
And I called it winter layover.
What I liked about
the shot was it
looked like a
serigraph painting.
It doesn't look so much
like a true photograph.
And it's just largely
because of the aluminum
gray is wearing through
this thin paint.
The bright overcast
light gave it
a kind of a different quality.
And I shot it with a
tight shot so that I made
it an abstraction of the boats.
But it's been one of
my favorite photos
and it was the only saving grace
I had out of that entire trip.
I've not been back
to Russia since.
I had Russian handlers that
would get me so drunk on vodka
that I can't even look
at vodka to this day.
These are stories that do not
go out of the room, right?
Any place on the planet
that intrigues me I'll
wind up going there.
And one of the places
was Ellesmere Island,
the large island to
the west of Greenland.
It's the most northern
land in the Canadian Arctic
archipelago.
And when I got up there, it
was in March, very, very cold,
56 below zero with
the wind chill factor.
These are some of the shots.
Arctic fox would come up
near my camp late in the day,
beautiful inquisitive.
But it was these stupid
rabbits, these 25 pound Arctic
hares that really were so fun
to watch because they would
virtually stand up on their
back legs and duke it out
like they're trying to hit
each other in the face.
So those are strange things.
I was traveling with
high school friends once.
We went up to Churchill.
We rented a little mobile
car with tracks on it
and went out and
photographed polar bears.
And I remember sitting on top of
this little vehicle that wasn't
much higher off the ground.
It had a hatch on that.
We'd photograph it, and
then invariably and always
the polar bears would come
towards us, because they
were extraordinarily curious.
And so there was a real art
of how late do you stay up
on top of the vehicle before
you close and make sure
you lock the latch.
This would be three or four
years before Tundra Buggies,
an entire tourist
industry came to Churchill
to photograph polar bears.
This was just some
high school friends
that were going
out there traveling
amongst polar bears that were
very, very curious at the time.
It still remains to
be an amazing place
to see these great bears.
And impact in a
month's time I'll
be back there for the first
time in about 20 years.
I traveled up there on other
occasions in early March
when the first day
a mother bear comes
out of a den with her
three cubs, very first day.
We were there a week
waiting for this to happen.
And we finally found that to
be in the late afternoon light.
The last of those three
cubs is definitely
the runt of the litter.
On the west coast
of Somerset Island,
3,000 whales congregate
in the river estuaries.
And they're mammals
just like we are.
They slough off
skin once a year.
Where we kind of lost a little
flake here or there all year
long, they lose it all at once.
And they come into
these shallow rivers
and they wiggle in the gravel.
But from an aerial
perspective to look and see
all these beautiful white whales
in one glance, 3,000 of them,
is a pretty amazing sight.
And when you walk
along the shore,
they'll literally swim close to
you and watch you walk along.
They're called the sea canary
because they're very animated.
They have all these
chirps and sounds.
Most people see
whales briefly, right?
You just see a fin
and then it's gone.
It's underwater.
It's a real mystery
for most of us.
But these little beluga
whales, which are 15 feet long,
they're more like a dolphin
in a way, really animated.
One year I spent
$25,000 on the hunch
that we could go across
the Drake Passage
and locate the first
colonies of emperor penguins
on the Weddell Sea.
Well $25,000 that many years
ago was a lot of money for me,
and it is still a
lot of money for me.
But we spent 11 days in Punta
Arenas, the most southern city
on the planet, waiting
for the weather to clear.
And then we all
got in a DC-6, we
meaning the four people
I was traveling with
plus an all women's expedition
that were heading to the South
Pole, a Japanese team that
was heading to the South Pole,
and one Norwegian.
And the rest of
us, the four of us,
were heading out
to the Weddell Sea,
the opposite direction
to see if there were
colonies of emperor penguins.
And these are 90 pound birds.
So they're about that
high off the ground.
They're extraordinary.
A lot is now known about it.
But when we went
down there, it was
speculated that they
actually existed down there,
but there was no proof.
So we flew down in a DC-6
and then got in Twin Otters
and flew out to the coast.
And we found these
colonies of 10,000
up against frozen icebergs
locked into place.
And the entire colony is mobile.
If the wind shifts,
they all kind of
move around these blocks
of ice for wind protection.
And these photos were taken
at-- well, the following day
it was overcast, but this
shot was shot at 2:30
in the morning in the
month of November,
which are the longest days
of the summer down there.
So they have one chick.
They arched their heads
over the one chick.
And they make this
very beautiful sound.
And what they're doing
is imprinting their sound
on that chick, because when
they all go out to sea,
they all are identical except
for their individual sounds.
So that chick's got to be
able to locate their parents
or die trying.
So it's a very
interesting story.
I would travel back and
back again over the years
to the Himalayas.
I have been up to the
Baltoro Glacier and up to K2
in the Karakoram
range of Pakistan.
I've spent a lot of time
in Mongolia, Bhutan, Nepal.
And on one occasion we
traveled across Western China
to the Khunjerab Pass and
dropped down into Pakistan.
And I'll remember this.
It was late in the
month of November.
The onslaught of winter
was surely coming.
And I saw this family coming
out of the high pastures
of the Himalayas.
And very interesting family.
There was two camels.
The first contained the wife
and kids all on one camel,
and then all their
supplies and their bedding
and their supplies
on the second camel.
But it was riding
that little donkey
that wasn't much bigger than a
dog that really was remarkable.
It was those kind of scenes
that you see, you photograph,
and you'll remember for
the rest of your lives.
I started working on books.
I initially did work for
"National Audubon" magazine,
for "Smithsonian," and
"National Geographic."
And then I started
working on books.
And I've been fairly prolific,
although it came as a shock
that this book that
I'm talking about
is my 100th book,
because I had no clue.
You could tell me I had done 40
and I wouldn't even bat an eye.
I don't keep track of
those kind of details.
One of the books was
called "Migrations,"
and virtually it was patterns
of animals on a world scale,
from schools of fish under
the sea to, in this case,
little brown bats
that were tucked away
in a cave in Kentucky,
in the Ozarks.
And I remember I was in
there with a professor
from the University of--
those senior moments
will come to all of you.
So you just breathe and you
change the dialogue-- Arkansas,
there you go.
It's like Tourette's.
You just pull it back out.
Anyway, I remember crawling
on my knees for about 3/4
of a mile with a
flashlight in my mouth.
And the cave wasn't much higher.
And an entire world population
of little brown bats
hibernate in these caves.
And with much fanfare
and a lot of pleading,
the professor who did
a census every year
allowed me to crawl
into this cave.
He says, "It's not
going to be fun."
I said, "I'm ready for it."
And so I came eventually
out of about 35 minutes
of crawling on my knees into
this tiny little chamber,
completely black.
There's no odor.
There's nothing.
It's just quiet, and then
you turn on the light.
And it looks like
a carpet above you.
These bats are like
300 per square foot.
So they're all hibernating.
And then he tells
me, "You have like
five minutes because
the heat of your body
will start to wake them up.
And if they wake
up, they're going
to burn enough
calories that you're
going to wind up killing a
bunch of these endangered bats."
So in the dark I'm trying to
use flash and photograph them
and not stand up
because my head would
crush all these little bats.
So these are some of the
memories for "Migrations."
Once I have an idea
for a book, I really
don't stop until
I've got what I want.
I would fly in an
ultralight over Africa
with this crazy French pilot,
and we would just scoot
down right on the top of grass.
Another minute we'd be 500
feet above the ground circling
over herds of wildebeest or
Cape buffalo in this case.
Life is interesting.
This is a lake in the Rift
Valley with flamingos.
I previsualized the shot
out of Jackson, Wyoming
where we would shoot
this right at sunset
so it would be
all about shadows,
not so much about the elk.
So this was "Patterns."
This was a book
that was inspired
by the work of MC Escher.
Another book I did was
called "Endangered People."
It was sanctioned by
the United Nations
and it was published
by the Sierra Club.
And I would travel.
This was shortly after
coming back from Everest.
And so I would go into
Irian Jaya and photograph
the Dani people like
this, one of the oldest
if not the oldest agricultural
societies on the planet.
And they were only discovered
during World War II when
American pilots were flying over
New Guinea and the Irian Jaya,
and they looked down
through the clouds
and they saw fields in a
place that nobody knew there
was a population of people.
So as late as the 1940s nobody
knew about the Dani people.
So I went in there
and photographed them.
They cultivate
gourds, and that's
what they wear on their penis.
And that's all their clothes.
That's the extent
of their clothes.
Today, there's no doubt baseball
caps and T-shirts and shorts,
but basically the same people.
They've been overrun
by the Javanese
from the island of Java.
But Irian Jaya is the Western
portion of Papua New Guinea.
Five more minutes, OK.
Well, all right, I'm
just going through.
So "Tribes" was a book.
I traveled all over
the earth photographing
technologically
primitive cultures, ones
that specifically
adorn themselves
during ceremonial occasions.
These were the Xingu
Indians in the Amazon basin.
And at the end of
a big ceremony,
they would have this
wrestling match.
From my perspective, I
love and I'm motivated,
and what gets me out of bed
is working on a project that
will see the light of day.
I love to inspire, to
educate, to inform people.
And basically all
the work I've done,
whether it's culture,
wildlife, landscapes, is
about inspiring people.
And it's been a great life.
Two days ago I was
up in the San Juans
photographing breaching orcas.
Two weeks ago I was on
a volcano in the Congo
photographing the world's
largest lava lake.
I spent a week in the wintertime
in South Georgia Island
in an all out blizzard
with something
like 100,000 king penguins
working on a book called
"The Living Wild."
So it's been a great life.
For "The Living Wild,"
I spent two weeks
trying to find and
photograph a wild panda.
Almost all pandas
you've ever seen
have been photographed
in captivity.
They look somewhat
natural, but a wild panda
is a very tough subject to get.
Tigers were believed
to be-- were
heading towards extinction.
The leading biologists
in the late '80s
were predicting that there would
no longer be any tigers left
in the wild by the year 2000.
And in fact this year,
this year and last year,
there's been a tiger boom.
So there's a lot of
good stories out there
that wouldn't necessarily get
to you through the chatter
of the news which
highlights, you know,
atrocities and bad stories.
But there's more
whales in the ocean
than there has been
in the last 50 years.
There's more mountain
lions in the United States
than there has been
in the last 200 years.
So there's a lot of
really positive stories
that don't necessarily
get out there.
Volcanoes are a love of mine.
I love the power, the
awe inspiring look
of being around a volcano.
I've done a lot
of work on Hawaii.
I've spent time on
the top of Mount Etna.
Last year, I traveled to
Iceland when the earth was
bleeding this river of lava.
And can you imagine hovering
in a helicopter at 12
below zero, and then a
change in the wind comes up
and it's 65 degrees?
And that's part
of the experience.
And this river of lava was
coming out of the earth.
It was like the earth was
bleeding blood and fanning out
into this giant delta.
And a week and a half after I
was out of there, it stopped.
And that's the unpredictable
nature of the volcano.
This was shot-- this
is not in the book,
but this was shot two
weeks ago in the Congo.
And it's at 11,000 feet.
I thought I would bring
enough clothes for this.
I'm on the equator, and I am
absolutely freezing to death.
And below us was this
cauldron of a lake,
largest volcanic lake on the
planet, which didn't look
like much until it got dark.
And then you could see it.
And we arrived on the
summit around 4:00 PM.
And at 4:35, a fissure
opened up and started
bleeding, all that
lava that's coming
down out of that opening.
So pretty extraordinary stuff
to see that, to photograph that.
Undoubtedly this will
go into a book that
will come out in about three or
four years called "Primordial."
On that trip, we
also photographed
the annular eclipse of the sun.
So this is the moon
in front of the sun.
It's much rarer of a phenomenon
than the total eclipse
of the sun.
And that's what it looks like.
So you know what, I
think that's a good place
to end this narrative, because
I know we also have questions.
This would be maybe
the appropriate time,
because otherwise I've
got like three hours.
No, let me just show
you one more thing,
just because I know you guys
like this kind of stuff.
Hold on just a sec.
I did a film with an
Australian group of filmmakers.
Look at all that
we're missing here.
It's a good thing you called me.
And it's now on Netflix.
It's called "Tales By Light."
So I had a crew of photographers
come out from Sydney.
They're all in their 20s.
And they kept
calling me grandpappy
with their Australian accent.
But we got along really well.
So we went to Africa.
We went to New Guinea.
We went to Ethiopia, Uganda.
And they had a
little [? Robie ?],
which is a little vehicle
that we could put a camera on.
And when we were doing the
Maasai Mara, East Africa,
we could hear lions in the
bush, but we couldn't quite
get the car to where they were.
So we put the camera on
this, drove it in there.
And we could hear
all this chatter.
And I said quickly
reverse it out,
and I'm taking pictures as
we're reversing the little car.
And all these kittens
were following it.
And you could see the
mother in the middle.
And to get shots that we cannot
have gotten handful of years
ago, a 16 wide angle and
mother's picking up the baby
right in front of the camera
from a perspective like that.
I think that's part of
what really excites me
as a photographer.
Technology is changing so fast.
It's hard to keep up with
it, by it's enabling me
and my colleagues
to photograph shots
that were only mere dreams
ago, from the stars at night
to these new perspectives.
This guy was a little
pissed off at this camera
on this [? Robie ?]
as we call it.
It literally picked up the
entire endeavor by the lens
and tossed it about
seven feet in the air.
So maybe that's an appropriate
place to end there.
All right, so I do--
how are we doing?
DAVID: Oh, it's up to you.
ART WOLFE: I do travel
quite a bit, as you know.
And on some of those occasions
I take people back to places
I really love.
One of those places is Myanmar.
Myanmar is a place
that's changing fast,
because when I first went
there about 10 years ago,
there was hardly any tourism.
And now every year
there's a lot more.
But it's still an
amazing place to go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
ART WOLFE: So that's enough
of a commercial there.
But people that go with us
have a great amount of time.
We set up good shots.
We know the area.
So if you're inclined,
just talk to me afterwards.
Otherwise I'm very happy to
talk to you about anything
you might want to
ask a question about.
DAVID: Please come up
here and ask questions.
ART WOLFE: Don't be shy.
I should acknowledge
Rob Shepard.
He has worked with us
for a number of years.
He was the editor on this book.
He used to be the
managing editor
for "Outdoor Photographer."
So our history goes
back a long time.
I think he and Deirdre
Skillman in my office
did a great book on
putting this book together.
And it's the first time I
can look back with clarity
and know when it happened.
So for old people like
me it's really important.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that technology has actually
changed landscape
photography quite a bit.
So I wonder, do you always
go back to your trusty SLR
or do you explore other
things like smartphones?
ART WOLFE: You
know, the answer is
I photograph with everything.
I have a smartphone that allows
me to photograph in the moment.
And many of those photos
populate my lectures.
So yeah, I'm not
a snob about it.
If you take a workshop
from me or travel with me,
I don't engage in
whether one camera
is better than the other.
It's all about what
the subject is.
And the camera you've
got in your hand
is the one you should be using.
So, yeah, all those cameras.
I have high end cameras,
but I also have the phones.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are
some tips that you
could give to people who
do work the nine to five
that still want to be good
photographers, especially up
here in the Pacific
Northwest, just to encourage
them to get out and shoot?
ART WOLFE: Yeah, you know,
you live in the Northwest,
and we live, I believe, in
the best part of the country
because an hour and a
half drive from Seattle,
you can be in the
northern steppe forest,
out on the coast,
in the mountains,
in the old growth
forest-- I mean,
there's so much at a
really quick access point.
There's a lot of
lectures being given.
I teach a lot of workshops.
I think just getting out there
and discovering the place
that you-- I would
presume many of you
have moved here from
out of the state.
There's an amazing array
of subjects to shoot.
And I think it's just
great for the soul.
I mean, I love to work
seven days a week.
I never take a vacation.
For me, taking pictures
actually delivers energy to me.
So I love that fact.
Creative types, people
that are creative,
whether it's cooking or
dance or poetry or writing,
photography, they live longer
lives than the average person
because the word is passion.
If you have that passion,
in anything, do it to help.
I sound like an
evangelist on the stage,
but it's really true.
I study a lot of art history.
And the famous artists, if
they didn't drink themselves
to death, they lived long lives.
So yes, anyway?
AUDIENCE: So what do you
think about drone photography?
ART WOLFE: I love
drone photography.
I think drone photography is
offering us points of view
that you would
not otherwise see.
So you know, it's like
one of those things.
There's a love-hate
relationship, right?
People don't like the sound
of a drone over their head,
but they love looking
at the pictures.
We all saw the BBC's
"Planet Earth,"
and many of the photos
in "Planet Earth"
were shot from drones.
And the same people
that love that
are the first ones that would
complain if they hear a drone.
So you know, I think being
pragmatic is really critical.
It gives us an
opportunity not to have
to hire a helicopter,
which is much louder
and noisier and intrusive.
But like everything else,
drones have their place.
And they have a lot of places
where they shouldn't be flying.
And a lot of people that
don't know how to fly it
should not be flying.
So I think it's already at the
point where you need a license,
and you need to be smart.
The minute some yahoo from--
I forget where they were.
I think they were French-- flew
it into the Grand Prismatic
Spring in Yellowstone, the
entire National Park system
banned them from the parks.
So there you go.
But I do love the technology
of seeing something
from a different point of view.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what, if any,
postprocessing have you done
or have you experimented with?
And what did you think
about the stuff--
ART WOLFE: So postprocessing
in the digital means making
your image look
analogous to the film
that you may have been
using prior to switching
from film to digital.
So what we do in Lightroom
is 25 points of vibrancy,
five points of saturation,
a little bit of contrast.
And bing, bang, boom,
you're basically
like a piece of Velvia
film that we would use.
That's pretty much
the extent of it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So how do you
balance the taking pictures
and the postproduction?
How much time do you
take culling your photos
and then processing them?
ART WOLFE: OK, great question.
So at any given
day-- for instance,
as I've just indicated, I
was in Africa two weeks ago.
And that was a 10 day trip.
Every day before I
go to bed, I would
see everything I
shot during the day,
and pull the favorites
into a collection,
and more than likely work on
them until 1:00 in the morning
before I go to bed.
Because I know if I
didn't do it then,
it's not going to
happen the next day
because there's all
these new photos that
are going to be shot.
So I'm compulsive
on getting it done.
Yesterday afternoon, I
was being driven back
from the San Juan Islands.
And I had the laptop on my lap.
And I was working on the images.
And I think they
got posted today.
So I don't ever delay it.
It's done right on
the day I shoot.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ART WOLFE: It helps
to be type A. Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So with the transition
from film to digital,
is there anything you found that
you had to unlearn or relearn
or do differently?
ART WOLFE: It was
remarkable to me
because the people
in my office said--
and I have a staff
that go back 26 years.
Several of the women in my
office have gone back 26 years.
And they told me when the 12
megapixel camera came out,
you either buy one
or you're going
to be a dinosaur,
because we were
doing a lot of testimonials
for film and technology.
So I got a digital camera.
I got a computer.
I got hard drives.
I got all the things you
would need to shoot digitally.
And then I went
off to Antarctica
with 500 rolls of film
and my film camera.
And on the route south across
the Drake Passage, I went out
and I thought OK,
I've got to find out
what the heck digital is about.
So I took a pitcher
of water beating up
and rain out on the
side of the boat.
And five minutes
later I was uploading
it to see if I can do that.
And when I saw
the image come up,
virtually I never have
taken a shot of film.
So it was absolutely
like a meat cleaver.
The switch from film-- and all
500 rolls of film came back.
And I gave that film away.
I didn't even sell it.
I just gave it away.
So it's all about the image.
And that was when digital
was on par with film.
Now it's outpaced it tenfold.
And it keeps getting better
and better and better.
I'm able to shoot
breaching orcas on Sunday
afternoon that they
would have been
all but impossible with film.
So there's no regrets.
There's no looking back.
I can make the digital
capture look like any film
that I preferred.
So I know that many of my
colleagues struggled with that.
They love their film.
I'm not emotional about that.
It was about the subject and
whether I could get it better.
Thank you for that question.
AUDIENCE: Pointers about
shooting in Antarctica?
I'm going there in December.
So any advice on
photography in Antarctica,
I would much appreciate it.
ART WOLFE: If you're
going to Antarctica,
I think that if you bring--
what kind of camera do you use?
AUDIENCE: A Nikon.
ART WOLFE: Nikon.
And with Canon, they
have a 100 to 400 zoom.
Nikon undoubtedly has
something that equates to that.
And if you don't own it,
then you could rent it.
You don't have to go out
and buy expensive equipment
for one trip.
But that would be a great
one because really, you
don't need much more than 400.
You know, I use wide
angles and midranges.
You know, the
penguins are close.
The landscape's big.
Unless it's an iceberg that
you can't get close to,
there is no reason to
bring big glass down there.
So 100 to 400 would
be really adequate.
AUDIENCE: How do you deal with
the weight and the walking?
So that's been a big--
[LAUGHTER]
ART WOLFE: There's
not much weight.
AUDIENCE: 200 to
500, that's pretty--
ART WOLFE: 100 to 400 is a lens
of about that big and about
that.
You can carry that,
one camera body.
Even today you don't
really need a tripod.
I mean, there are times where
I bring a tripod always,
like the volcanoes
at night or stars.
But for the most part, today--
I used to advocate tripods
on everything.
But today you really don't
know-- you know, frequently
with the high end Canon
cameras that I use,
I'm shooting at ISO 4,000.
Noise is more of a
manifestation of length
of shutter speed than ISO.
And so I can shoot all day
long with ISO 4,000 or 2,000
and tweak it a little
bit with noise reduction,
and I'm good to go.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you just need
a thick [INAUDIBLE] 4,000
and just shoot,
shoot, shoot, or do
you send it to an auto
ISO, 4,000 to the max?
ART WOLFE: I don't use
auto ISO, although I have
friends that just swear by it.
When I'm shooting
a breaching whale,
like I was on Sunday afternoon,
and I have no clue where
they're going to come
up, in a 360 degree view,
I put it at 4,000 so
I could shoot at f/22.
And so I found that
I was just reacting.
And if the whale was within
a fairly big radius, at f/22.
It's going to be in focus.
I don't have time to
even switch and try
to focus because the whale's
gone, underwater again.
So that's why those faster
ISOs really serve me.
Right after the eclipse images
I shot, I was along a river.
And I had-- and if you
look on our website,
you'll see these photos.
Giant hippos and crocodiles
were duking it out.
So ISO 4,000 gave me depth
of field and shutter speed
when they were happening.
And I'm not really
compromising quality.
I also have a 50
megapixel camera
that I always shoot at ISO
100 for the big landscapes.
But for action type
shots, 4,000 now
is frequently what I'm using.
I'm not a tech-- I really don't
like talking about technology,
but it would be ridiculous
not doing it in this group.
DAVID: You get the
honor of last question.
ART WOLFE: You better make
this damn question good,
because this is
the very last one.
AUDIENCE: Well is
there any anyplace
that you haven't been
that you want to go?
ART WOLFE: Yeah, I
want to go to Socotra.
Does anybody want to
go to Socotra with me?
You want to go?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
ART WOLFE: It's an
island off Yemen.
It's only accessed through
the capital of Yemen.
It's halfway to Somalia.
And they have the most bizarre
tree life on the planet.
So that's why I
want to go there.
And I've been waiting.
I waited eight
years for the Congo
to quiet down before I went in.
I have no delusions
that I'm going to become
a mercenary photographer.
I waited until there was a peace
treaty signed in Goma, Congo
before I went up
on that volcano.
I think Sanaa, which is
the capital of Yemen,
has quieted down.
I just want to get
out to that island.
I want to go to Oman.
I want to go to Saudi
Arabia and that area.
Israel I've not been to.
So there's pockets
that I've not been to.
I've not been to
Spain yet, though I
have five books on Spain.
So I know all about Spain.
But I've relegated a lot
of the easier countries
to places that I'll
go in my old age.
So I just had a
birthday yesterday.
I turned 65.
And I'm ready to go
tomorrow morning.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
though about going to space?
ART WOLFE: My staff has
really advocated that.
Yeah, get on that rocket.
No.
You know, there was a-- I
would love to photograph
the earth from orbit.
There's no question.
Any colleague of mine
would really like to do it.
Unless you're a billionaire,
that's been unaccessible.
Probably in my lifetime
it will be accessible.
So I'd love to do that.
OK David, thank you.
DAVID: Thank you very
much for coming today.
ART WOLFE: All right,
thanks everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.